[Applause]
this is the moment when the big twist
and interstellar is revealed
that cooper was the ghost interacting
with murph's bookshelf from the
beginning of the film
this is the moment we find out the big
twist in the prestige
that anger cloned and killed himself
every night to achieve his magic trick
and this is the moment we find out the
big twist in following
that bill is being framed for murder all
these scenes have something
in common and not just that they're
directed by christopher nolan
we see each of these scenes multiple
times in their movies
so how are scenes we've already watched
still able to deliver
such a big twist the secret lies in
nolan's use of recurrence
nolan uses the idea of recurrence in his
films in a myriad of ways
in inception recurrence is featured as a
main component of the plot
creating dreams within dreams in the
prestige
no one explores recurrence as a motif
the film features twins and clones
diaries within diaries and the main
characters repeatedly sabotaging each
other's magic tricks
and in memento the very structure of the
film is recursive
as the film constantly alternates
between scenes from the past
and scenes from the present put simply
recurrence is continued repetition
however one of nolan's greatest uses of
recurrence
is how he employs it to deliver twists
at the end of his films a simple first
example to help wrap your head around
how nolan uses recurrence to pull off
his twist endings
comes from a scene in the prestige that
nolan replays three times throughout the
film
at 47 seconds into the film we see a
bunch of top hats in a forest
when the scene cuts away from the hats
it's confusing we don't see the hats
again for another
hour and 25 minutes when we learn that
the hats have been duplicated by tesla's
machine
this time the scene makes a little more
sense however
the real significance of the hats isn't
revealed until nolan shows us the top
hats once again
right before his final reveal angier
achieves his magic trick by cloning
himself
every night using the same tesla machine
that duplicated the top hats
ultimately drowning each of his clones
so we see the scene
three times and our experience of it the
third time
is significantly different than when we
saw it the first time
suddenly the perplexing scene from the
opening now makes sense because of all
the context that we get throughout the
movie
and even though the movie presents us
with everything we need to figure out
the significance of the opening image
which one is mine they're all your heads
mr ng
we don't tend to apply what we've
learned until the scene plays again
now one could argue that the scene is
just a simple flashback
but it's actually more than that while
many films and filmmakers use flashbacks
and non-linear storytelling what makes
nolan's style distinct is that he
doesn't
back just once in his films instead of
structuring his non-linear films to have
distinct sections that are out of order
chronologically
like pulp fiction the non-linear
structures of nolan's films
constantly flash back and forth between
distinct timelines adding more and more
context to each timeline with each
recurrence
until ultimately everything makes sense
now using recurrence does not at all
make a film
inherently better but it does happen to
be an extremely helpful technique when
trying to create a twist ending
even among movies with twist endings
nolan's use of recurrence
sets his films apart from the rest for
example in the film the usual suspects
there is certainly a twist at the end of
the film but it's a one and done reveal
the seemingly meek verbal was lying
throughout the film and is actually the
fabled crime boss
kaiser soze so while it's an
entertaining twist
ending the film purposefully misleads
the audience throughout the majority of
the film
and there are very few clues placed
throughout that lead the audience to the
truth about verbal's identity
however in nolan's films the audience is
almost always given the opportunity to
solve the mystery through recursively
presented clues and scenes that are
shown over
and over again take for example the
opening shot of inception
where a haggard cobb washes up on a
beach and talks with an old man
this scene is revisited again at the end
of the film now that the audience
understands the context and realizes
what's going on that this beach is limbo
and that cabba has traveled there in
order to save
saito the old man nolan even shows a
very similar scene of cabin ariadne
washing up on the beaches of cobb's
limbo but he doesn't leave enough time
for the audience to process the
significance of washing up on the beach
and its connection to the short scene
that happened two hours before
nolan is constantly presenting the
audience with all of the answers
throughout his films but we just don't
quite know what to look for
until he shows us right at the very end
the fact that nolan is able to
repeatedly show the audience the truth
without them realizing what's happening
is what makes his films so iconic while
the twist of the usual suspects is like
telling you that the duck you've been
staring at is actually
a rabbit the twist and nolan's films are
more like a hidden puzzle
there's a colorful image or scene that
doesn't make sense when you look at it
the first time
however when nolan finally gives the
audience the key and you revisit the
image
you can see things clearly this is why
revisiting nolan scenes are such a twist
the answer has been there the whole time
hiding in plain sight
even nolan's films that don't have
traditional twist endings have recursive
elements
for example in dunkirk he shows the same
scene from several different
perspectives
which results in a miniature twist well
initially it appears that the pilot
collins
is fine after being shot down by an
enemy plane waving to the other pilot
when nolan later cuts to colin's
perspective of the event it turns out
that he is actually not okay
his waving is actually him struggling to
open his cockpit while he slowly begins
to drown
while this is one of the most basic
examples of nolan's recurrence
it shows how such a simple tool can be
so powerful
luckily knowing how nolan works won't
necessarily ruin your experience
watching his films as cutter famously
says at the end of the prestige
now you're looking for the secret
but you won't find it because of course
you're not really looking
you want to be
you